beaucoup. On l'a vu pendant la
pandémie, si vous marchez à
beaucoup de personnes qui
étaient et ont manqué
de refuge.
Mon invité est Lou
il fait parti de l'ADN de
Montréal.
Vous arrivez comme préside du
conseil d'administration d'une
institution à Montréal,
c'est une scission On va voir ls
à l'écrpassage, c'est un jet
également pour la nuit,
mais vous voulez agrandir.
332 lits disponibles, 20 000
personnes qui passent. Voulez en
faire plus.
- Oui, disons que pour se
d'urgence avec 475 lits. Ce sont
des lits d'urgence dans des
dortoirs. Mais nous opérons
eux sont des logements dans des
édifices où lesiresiresiresiress
acceptent de loger notre
clientèle. Et l'autre tiers
c'est des logement
avons bâtis au fil du temps
Cette année nous somme en train
de bâtir un autre 100.
gens qui sont des traits et de
les aider à passer à une autre
étape dans leur vie.
emploi, de les aider à app
Éventuellement les gens peuvent
voler de leurs propres ailes
- En attendant, on dit,
à Laval, il manque de place dans
le refuge.
- C'est exact. Un lus
grand Montréal qui compte à peu
près 35el,
on ramasse à peu près... 14
millions
7 millions nous viennent des
gouvernetre 7 millions
de le trouver. Il faut demander
l'aide des citoyens, mais
e à un gros
rôle à jouer là-dedans
pour donner. Moi j'ai eu le
plaisir de diriger la campagne
à peu près 30 millions.
Cette année on va lancer une
d'environ 50 millions,
l'entreprise privée les
fondations qui amènent les
fonds. C'est des fondsd'exploits
fonds de capital.
malheureusement les besoins ont
augmenté, est-ce que les deu
grandes familles, le
gouvernement et les entreprises
privées doivent en faire
- Il n'y a aucun doute fort
faire davantage. Voyez-vous, le
recensement n'a pas encore les
chiffres mais on c
réponse. Il y a 60
en situation d'itinérance au
Québec, dont la mo
Montréal. Si vous faites la
somme des lits disponibles, vous
n'en ave
Vous en ...
quelque chose comme ça.
Ce n'est pas suffisant et on
s subventions
du gouvernement fédéral dans une
moindre mesure du gouvernement
ver et mettre
à disposition des logements
des personnes qui sont en
situation d'itinérance.
La mission elle-même n'est pas
capable de payer ça. C'est les
- La question est seings, n'en s
collectivement?je n'ai je n'ai .
Tout ce que je peux vous dire cl
d'administration avec qui j'ai
le plaisir de travailler, on
changer les choses. Pour faire
leur part, pour essayer d'am
la mission un nouveau niveau.
croissance, mais malheureusement
la demande s'impos
il y a beaucoup de gens qui
tombent en situati
d'aide et notre travail se
décide les aider.
- Vous
objectifs, qu'est-ce que vous
voulez faire le temps que vous
serez à la mission?
- Écoutez, mon ambition ce
serait de réussir à coordonner
le ministère de la santé avec le
l'habitatil'habitatil'habitatil.
Pour qu'on est des plans plus
efficaces pour construire plus
de logements. Mais ces fonds là,
c'est des fonds qui viennent,
en ce qui concerne le capital,
largement de ta voix et en cet .
L'entreprise privée va faire sa
part, mais malheureusement, ilfe
davantage.- Vous venez de pronot
important : de coordonnées. On a
l'impression que d
d'urgence, il y a beaucoup
d'intervenants il
de fouillis et malheureusement
on ne voit pas assez les
résultats concrets et
rapideme
- Ce que je sais ce qu'il y a un
sociaux. Il y a une démarcation
entre la précarité économique,
les vont
tomber. Ils peuvent être évincés
de leur logement, peuvent avoire
substances ou de jeux.un décès s
la famille, ces gens-là peuvent
tomber dans l'itinérance.......e
message est très clair.
Les gens d'affaires, on dit que,
le monde anglophone devrait
dire... c'est davantage dans
leur habitude de d
choses-là. Vous le constatez?
insulter personne. C'est un fait
que le don moyen d
francoph
fait se documenter.
Je ne dis pas ça pour blâmer
personne
est dans l'espoir
qu'ils vont être généreux avecet
faire.tait parlétait parlétait -
là, vous aviez lancé cette idée
du salaire minimum à 20 $ en les
sociales, économiques sont trop
% et le cadre...
1 % des plus riches possède
de la richesse.
Les 50 % des moins
Depuis trois ans o
l'impression qu'on a réduit la
pauvreté un peu. C'est l'extrême
pauvreté
l'extrême richesse. Qu'est-ce
qu'on fait?
- Pour ce qui est du salaire
minimum 20 $, à l'époque l'idée
Mais le marché s'est occupé
de lever la rémunération des
gens qui étaient insuffisamment
payés. De plus en plus dù s'apù,
le Canada et le Québec en
général sont des pays, des é
où les inégalités économiques
sont moins élevées qu'ailleu
dans le monde. Est assez voisinn
Scandinavie. On a nous...
on a un système q
bon. Mais ce n'est jamais assez,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
corriger le reste, j'ai fait mon
petit bois avec le salaire
minimum
- et votre fondation, vous êtes
généreux.
- C'est un consensus social
social j'ai fait parti du
problème moi-même.
Les plus hauts rémunérés qui ont
un salaire de 200 fois leyés,
ça ne peut pas marcher. Si vous
êtes dans les pays scandinaves
allez être à peu près entre 40
et 60 fois le seul moyen.
Ils ne sont pas moins bon,
c'est parce qu'il y a un
consensus social s'est établi
que c'est comme ça que laionnern
veut qu'elle soit harmonieuse.
- Quand le message vient
d'hommes comme vous apportelus.
- J'espère que vous avez raison.
- Très bien, merc
Louis Auden d'être venu nous
voir dans notre st